today we're going to be speaking with
matthew tai known online as lao y 86 or
sea milk who's an american blogger well
known for living in china uh matthew so
great having you on i really appreciate
it
ah thank you so much it's an honor so i
mean i guess first just to kind of
orient our our audience how did you end
up living in china for the the period
that you did
yeah i'll give you the cliff notes
version but basically i was you know
bored out of college i didn't really
want to settle down and get a job
immediately um i had just backpacked
through europe i was like why not go
travel somewhere else
uh china wasn't even on my list i was
like why not do some sort of gap year
maybe teach you know teach english
abroad for a year and then come back
home and then get a job so i initially
thought you know taiwan sounds pretty
cool
uh interested in maybe learning mandarin
chinese might be useful in the future
so i put up my resume on some taiwanese
job sites and it just wasn't hiring
season at the time
uh but i guess some mainland chinese
companies also poach like potential
employees on those sites as well because
i got a phone call from this like tiny
tiny little school in guangdong in
huizhou actually the picture behind me
is the city behind me um called me up
and said hey do you want to do a year
here instead and i you know i didn't
really consider i was like you know
china is a pretty seems like a pretty
crazy place but at the same time why not
go on another adventure and try it out
and
you know i sold all my stuff i was just
a young you know 22 year old kid and uh
hopped on a plane and went over there
and
i have a number of viewers who have
called me sometimes when we'll open up
our phone lines and they say that they
are in china teaching english
um
what other things do americans sometimes
do in china when they're there
sure yeah like so i didn't continue
teaching english the entire time it's
kind of just your it's the way you get
when you get off the plane it's what you
do right but a lot of people you know
they'll oversee factories they'll um
do consultation for like uh what's it
called like quality control they'll do
um help with immigration visas and stuff
for people that want to move abroad
um there's people that will start their
own bars you know it's like a it's not
an open market but it's a huge market so
a lot of people especially during
china's golden period which i call like
kind of like when i was there
2008 up until i mean i left in around
2018 but up until like 2014 was like a
golden period for people to go there
and try out a new market go try a new
product try to get chinese people
interested in something that they can
find a home that is not already popular
in china so
there's how to even broach this next
part i mean there's no shortage of
reporting about
an authoritarian status quo in china to
different degrees and affecting
different people
we have um
the uyghur population specifically and
we've done interviews about that then
there's people like you who are
americans who may be there on a
temporary basis and your circumstances
presumably would be different than
someone who is from china and living in
china just to get us into this can you
give us a general overview of what's
accurate about the reporting that we
hear about the chinese government and
what maybe is is less accurate generally
speaking sure so when i was initially
there i mean i didn't set out to cover
any news or influence anything about
china um other than the fact that i
wanted to put out videos to show people
that it's not the boogie man like people
are like what are you doing over there
why did you move to such a crazy you
know communist authoritarian country uh
and i just wanted to put videos out
there to be like listen it's not it's
not as bad as what you think or maybe
the things that you're thinking of are
not actually true um at least in my life
from my perspective or my chinese
friends right so
that's what i initially did and um
i actually moved into as my channel got
bigger and stuff and i you know my
business partner people might know him
out there winston he's uh the first
china vlogger the first guy to actually
get on a vpn and put out videos from
china i happened to be the second we met
each other
we started doing tv shows we started
doing travel documentaries and again our
goal
was we set up a small motorcycle
business where we built our own custom
motorcycles we rode through the country
and we rode we didn't go through the
places like that you know people
normally see shanghai beijing we went
through the rural countryside we went
through the small towns the third tier
cities all these places that don't get
reporting
so we wanted to show
a human face of china and we didn't set
out to do that from the lens of like
oh this is so unfair the way it's
portrayed we just wanted to show reality
right
so from that perspective
we developed our own insight onto what
was actually happening in the country
and as we traveled more and the more
people and relationships we developed
the more we realized that
unfortunately a lot of stuff that people
talk about in regards to china are more
of a macro scale
but
china has a lot of issues and a lot of
them i'm going to say the majority of
them do stem from the chinese government
and when we would go to
some of these villages and find out that
maybe an official for example a local
official went unpunished after raping a
14 year old girl and then having her
murdered
we would be shocked to hear this and
it's weird because the people in this
village they normally probably wouldn't
talk about that to anyone else but
because we were foreigners that showed
up there was some sort of like trust or
understanding that they that we would
understand
we would kind of get their perspective
and we wouldn't stick around long enough
to face any repercussion and the more
people like that we met the more
beholden we felt to tell the story of
actually what's happening when we were
in
some of these far-flung areas we would
find out that the people's liberation
army of china would go and harass
families and harass tribes like
mongolian tribes and things like this
for money
to just keep them down their languages
were being banned out of schools
the people would tell us stories about
how they felt trapped because they're an
ethnic minority and china doesn't allow
them mobility or doesn't allow them to
do really anything especially upwards of
mobility owning their own business
making money
and we found out that there's actually a
lot more than what you know western
media is portraying i think the western
media portrays a lot of you know
financial based things or you know we'll
focus on one specific issue which is
great i mean like i i absolutely
focus on the uyghur issue it's a huge
thing i personally know uyghur people
that have gone through this i'm in
personal contact with people that have
lost their families to the genocide in
western china but also like the stories
of the inner mongolian people the
stories of the ethnic minorities in the
south
i became very dedicated to kind of
compiling these stories in my head while
i was there knowing i couldn't report
from china at the time and then saving
them for when i ultimately had to leave
china so let's dig into a couple things
you said you said you in some of the you
know third tier cities you wouldn't
stick around long enough that there
would be repercussions and then you just
said some of the stories you knew you
couldn't report on while you were there
why not why did you have to leave the
cities what would the repercussions be
what would happen if you tried to report
on them
so what happened was when we we would
have the the nicest of intentions let's
say we show up at a you know a third
fourth fifth tier city somewhere down in
guijo province let's just pick a random
province in the south
and what would happen is we would get
you know of course you show up you're a
foreigner from the middle of nowhere
like you're in the middle of nowhere
people crowd around you they want to
talk to you they want to take pictures
with all that kind of stuff that's
normal but
when you sit down with people and you
start sharing a meal when you start
talking about things and they you know
you're not inciting these conversations
they're they're bringing these things up
and they start talking about what life
is like there how they haven't received
any of the poverty you know alleviation
type funds how their their town
is going to be flooded by a dam that the
government's putting in even though that
nobody wants it there those
conversations perk the wrong ears so
like people will be in the background
people will be around there that have to
report to local communist party
officials and what will happen is
they'll find out you know through the
grapevine quite quickly that there's
foreigners there and that they're not
supposed to be there because there are
entire areas in china where foreigners
are not even supposed to be and you
don't hear about this is again you
wouldn't see this on reporting you
wouldn't read about this anywhere but
there are whole areas that are basically
blacklisted off because the chinese
government doesn't want another xinjiang
story to break they don't want another
tibet story to break they don't want
people talking about issues that are
caused by the government leaking out to
potential journalists even though we
weren't
so
you would have a situation where you'd
be in an area and then you'd kind of get
this inkling this feeling that
number one the hotels won't even let you
stay stay there they're like no we can't
register a foreigner you know whether
they got tipped off by someone or not
it's a different story but they just
won't even register you so you can stay
there so you're forced to leave anyway
but when you get the feeling that people
are starting to like make phone calls
and then you start to see police
officers and things like this you know
it's time to leave because the times
that we did stick around we've been told
by police officers that you actually
have to get on your bike and just get
the hell out of there wow and what we
notice sometimes is when we would be in
these areas later on we would see
actual police officers sometimes in
notepads or their phones
at certain kind of designated points on
the road from the next from where we
just left to the next city so we'd be
monitored the entire time and you
realize that you know especially when
you travel around rural china
you realize that it's very much akin to
the security apparatus that maybe like a
place like north korea would have it's
just not as in your face and it has more
money right
so you're minded the entire time and
ultimately we found out really how bad
it can get when we were up in inner
mongolia and you know our hotel room was
just full of swat team people
with body cameras and automatic weapons
that's when you realize that i'm here
trying to film some horses and talk to
some local people about their way of
life and then there's a swat team and
detectives in my hotel room
interrogating me about my every movement
in the entire country
um now when something like that happened
after they're done interrogating you do
they leave and then you just kind of
finish what you were doing
no that's that's the worst part is that
there's a a system of
i don't know i think they want to
instill some sort of paranoia because
what they'll do
is uh i'll use the example in the hotel
room with the swat team what they'll do
is be like
okay we didn't really get what we wanted
you know they they list off where we
work what our contracts were where we
shop 2 000 miles away by the way they
know everything about you and they want
to get in your head because later on
they'll continue to harass you so you
think everything's fine you'll leave
super early the next morning to go on to
your next destination and then you get
stopped by the army like that that later
that day uh early in the morning we got
stopped by the pla the people's
liberation army who made us take apart
all of our equipment check everything
take photos told us not to smile in the
photo stand in front of everything and
they would leave
and then immediately they would come
back and do the exact same thing over
and over again until you just get out of
their jurisdiction right at the same
time after your trip is over the police
still come to your house they come to
visit where you are they come to
interrogate you why why do you own a
drone why are you doing this right and
it's this constant kind of harassment
and it's
it's kind of the
the moment you realize that hey i'm not
welcome here with a camera they don't
want people they don't want foreigners
walking around with cameras talking to
people and so that kind of false
security you've built up over 10 years
you know you watch that shift with the
the current regime by the way this this
really came to fruition maybe around
2015 and started getting really bad
um but you watch
this happen and it breaks your heart and
it also makes you feel like what if if
the chinese government's trying to hide
this stuff so badly there is so there's
so much under the surface that people
don't actually know about and that's
what i feel
beholden you know i feel beholden to the
people to talk about today because i i
get thousands thousands of chinese
people reaching out telling me please
keep your voice up please keep talking
about this kind of stuff because we
can't talk about that stuff right right
the um the social credit system i i've
read quite a bit about it specifically
in the context of the uyghurs and we
interviewed jeffrey kane about his book
and he you know writes specifically
about how it's sometimes used uh to
restrict the movement of the weaker
people and in other ways can you talk a
little more generally just about how for
the average person living in china and
maybe there is no such thing maybe it's
very different urban versus rural or
whatever the case may be sure how does
that system affect the average person
yeah so the social credit system is i've
done a huge uh
basically a documentary series on the
whole thing
what it is is it's more of a dynamic
thing that's being tested out so i think
a lot of people you know i wanted to go
out there and dispel this myth that it's
some sort of number that hangs over your
head like a black mirror or something
it's not it's not that at all in fact it
was it was rolled out in this place
called rongchang in shandong in northern
china
and it was the first place that they
they rolled it out and it's no secret in
fact i found the
government documents that are out there
in public and i translated them myself
and that's what i based my video on
and what it did was teach me how it
works you know from a you know a test
standpoint testing out on this city and
its people which it's mandatory there
but it's not necessarily something
that's used elsewhere right there are
other cities in fact i reached out to a
lot of people around china to ask them
if they even knew about it i would say a
good chunk of people hadn't even heard
about it but then there were there were
cities there were other cities and like
in chengdu and then i talked to people
in anhui i talked to people all over
china that did know about it in fact
their city had some sort of version of
it and what it is it's really trying to
reward good behavior
with a point-based system and then
punish bad behavior and unfortunately
when i went through those documents and
i spoke to people around china
it
looks like it's trying to reward good
societal behavior which is probably a
fine it's a fine thing it's like uh you
know yeah i don't have a criminal record
so my score goes higher right but
unfortunately a good proportion of those
crimes of those things that lower your
score
are things about speaking out against
the government about posting uh messages
of dissent on on forums or on on chat
groups um you know uh having
weird religious beliefs as they call it
you know cult-like religious beliefs it
turns out that a lot of it is aimed at
reducing personal freedom
so that people don't dissent against the
government
once you're sort of branded or
stigmatized or assigned you know a
lesser status whether it's specifically
point-based or not
how do you recover from that how can you
how can you get back to sort of being on
on everyone's good side so to speak
well unfortunately if you're on like the
low
this is what i pointed out in my in my
video series is that when i spoke to
people there's no
even though there's a sliding scale of
points if the government deems you the
lowest score you just get the lowest
score there's no there's no rule of law
or rhyme or reason in this i think
people really rely on this western lens
of like everything works to a certain
standard everything works because of
rules and laws that's not really how it
works like if china wants to throw you
the lowest score and make you like
ostracize in society they'll just do
that right off the bat right especially
if it's something about the government
or destroy you in jail but if a person
is like labeled at the bottom i mean
your your kids probably aren't going to
get into schools right um you know
you're not going to be able to get
employment opportunities at least above
the lowest you know blue collar kind of
construct construction type jobs even if
you're well educated um
and to get out of that if you're at the
bottom you're not going anywhere but if
you to get out of that you have to do
good deeds right you have to uh
participate in in local government uh
activities you have to
i mean there are there are some clauses
in these documents that say if you rat
someone out basically that's doing bad
things then you get to move up it's
basically
a
really restrictive way of keeping people
in their spot they don't really want
people to go up or down necessarily
um
it's almost like there is no recourse
for people to
exit once they've already been deemed
that lower caste
last thing i want to ask about in a
couple minutes we have left you weren't
there during the coveted lockdowns but
it's been widely reported that you know
there are these videos of the
vehicles pumping out disinfectant on the
street which is of course of
questionable or no actual preventative
value for covert whatsoever the covet
zero strategy of a sort of close to
complete lockdown
um etc etc can you talk a little bit
about whether any of what
you read about in the context of covid
was surprising based on your experiences
when you did live live there
um no
honestly like when i see when i saw the
heavy-handed approach of you know xi
jinping's government
uh really not just when he took over but
like later on when he achieved full full
power within this within the chinese
government when he consolidated that
power through the anti-corruption drive
and things like this i wasn't surprised
to see what kind of methodology was
coming out with the the zero covert
policy because
there's a there's a thing within the
chinese government especially especially
true under the current leadership
is that they can't be wrong
so when the chinese government set out
to say hey look at the world failing
with the coveted response
look at we're going to be the ones that
kind of deal with it very harshly in the
beginning but we're going to show the
world as kind of as a brand how this
authoritarian style government actually
works right we can take away people's
personal freedoms and stuff but isn't
that better than dying isn't that better
than millions of people dying and
honestly it kind of worked in the
beginning i think a lot of people were
like you know china's pretty brutal but
at the same time you know look at how
they've dealt with this a lot of people
didn't die in comparison to the rest of
the world that's i guess if you believe
the numbers right i mean there's also a
question as to yeah but of course
yeah i'm always speaking uh like a
normal reader yes looking at the news
right right um let's pretend like you
believe the numbers so
then people are in a position to say you
know what this other style of governance
maybe they're not going to jump on and
be like yeah china is the future china's
the way but they'll look at it and say
you know what maybe this kind of
reporting that i see about china is not
really accurate right
and what happens is unfortunately when
you get new variants when you get
something that spreads so crazy like
omicron and then the rest of the world
has found out ways to deal with it
whether it be mrna vaccinations on
things that have been proven to work
china didn't adopt those things out of
face to save face to say that we have
our own homegrown method we have our own
vaccine which is not very effective by
the way again
we have our own lockdown strategies and
we've already put in the work so we
don't really have to suffer through this
anymore while you guys still have to and
the rest of the world's kind of saying
what do you mean like it's not number
one it's not as the the new variant's
not as bad number two a lot of our
population is vaccinated and number
three we have an actual dynamic approach
on how to deal with it that doesn't
necessarily restrict people's personal
freedoms
and china says no no blinders on we have
zero coved we have zero code we have
zero covered and that can't be proven
wrong because in the top down leadership
in china there is no there is no saying
that the government is wrong about their
strategy they have to be right and see
it through
and we're seeing where xi jinping is
currently trying to get into his third
term he has to make sure
that his policies
not only worked but nobody has any sort
of dissent or disapproval with them
right so we're looking at a situation
now where zero kovid is either going to
change and rebrand to the to save leader
leadership face or is going to continue
down this very draconian route
we've been speaking with matthew ty
known online as laowai 86 or sea milk
matthew's so great speaking to you and
really appreciate your insights
thank you so much david